Peace, mercy and blessings of God be upon you. Welcome,
may you be well, God willing. Here
today we have reached lesson 18,
part
four.
God is our helper. Let's go straight into this lesson.
Immediately, the
intransitive verb is "jalasa" (to sit), the transitive verb is "ajlis" (sit). A man sat. A man sat. An intransitive verb is "jalasa" (to sit). The second part is "al-jalasa" (the
second part). The teacher is at the institute.
Okay,
let's read
these verses. And in the revelation,
Yeah.
Q And We certainly
showed him all Our signs, but he denied and refused. And We certainly showed him
all Our signs, but he denied and refused. He is the One Who
shows you His signs and sends down provision for you from the sky. He is the One Who
shows you His signs and sends down provision for
you from the sky.
Transitive verb. And when
Abraham
said, “My Lord, show me how You give life to the dead,” Abraham said, “My Lord, show me how You give life to the dead.”
Abraham said, “Do you not believe?” He said, “Yes, but my
heart…” He said, “Do you not believe?” He said, “Yes,
but my
heart…” God said, “Yes, but my heart…”
Yes, I ask for this reason because
I want my heart to be assured.  Yeah.  To
reassure my heart.  And then say
this is the creation of Allah.
What have those besides Him created? So
basically, show me what
those besides Him can
create. We will place them
under our feet so that they will be among the lowest. And
those who disbelieved will say, "Our Lord, show us those who led us astray from among the
jinn and mankind, and place them under our feet so that they will be among the lowest."
[Music]
We will place them under our feet so that they will be among the lowest. The
oral
exercises have come.
And
he wants you to do the following.  Listen
carefully he wants the following to be
done.   The
teacher says to the student, "Your pen," and he replies, "I will show it to you in a little while, or I will not show it to you." The teacher
says to each student, "
Have you seen your notebook?" "
Yes, I have seen you." "I traveled
to the east and west of the
earth." "I traveled about so much." The
verb is a
doubled verb with meanings including
abundance
or exaggeration. Abundance and exaggeration. Abundance and
exaggeration. May
God reward you. "
Kafli Jaw," meaning "He made a lot," meaning "He traveled a lot." "Tajawwal," meaning "He traveled a lot." "Tawf," meaning "He traveled a lot." "Tawf," meaning "He traveled a lot." "Tawf," meaning "He traveled a lot." "Tawf," meaning "He traveled a lot." "Qad qatala," meaning "He killed," meaning "He went to extremes
in killing," meaning "He went to extremes in killing." "Kasara," meaning "He broke," meaning "He went to extremes in breaking," meaning "He broke to extremes in breaking." "Qata'a," meaning "He cut to extremes in
cutting," meaning "He cut to extremes in cutting." "Ad kathiran," meaning "He counted a lot." "Ad kathiran," meaning "He counted a lot." "
Kasarat al-aqlam," meaning "The pens were broken." "Kasarat al-aqlam," meaning "The pens were broken."
Here, abundance means "He was
over."
In the revelation: "Indeed, those who deny Our verses
and are arrogant toward them - the gates of heaven will not be opened for them,
nor will they enter His Paradise until a camel passes through the eye of a needle." ...
They have the gates of heaven, but they will not enter Paradise
until the camel passes through the eye of the needle. [
Laughter]
The Quran, the one who gathered wealth and counted it, the one who gathered wealth and
counted it,
10 prayers, God willing. Okay,
maybe we can pray Isha at 9:15.
He said, "We will kill their sons."
He said, "
We will kill the sons of
Pharaoh." And the gates were
closed, and the gates were closed. So We made them stories and tore them apart completely. So We made them stories and tore them apart completely. And We saved you from the people of
Pharaoh, who were afflicting you with the worst of
punishments, slaughtering your sons. And when
We saved you from the people of Pharaoh, who were afflicting you with the worst of punishments, slaughtering your sons. So remember when We saved you from the people of Pharaoh, who were afflicting you with the worst of punishments, slaughtering your sons. This
hadith is a warning.
This is a warning,
and it is alerting the listener to something disliked so that he may avoid it. It is an
alert.  The one being warned
about something disliked, so that he may avoid it, is
good,
God willing. 91 15 May
God reward you. God willing, we will pray the
Isha prayer at 9:15, God willing. God willing, okay. And it is
the warning to the one being addressed about the disliked
[music]
Affair Despiso
Examples: Beware of dogs, my son. Beware of dogs, my son. Beware of dogs, my son. Beware of dogs, my son. Beware of dogs, my sons. Beware of dogs, my
sons.
Beware of dogs, my sons.
[music]
Way you know, yeah, don't know. They know
you now. If you want, so yeah, no escape. Yeah, so this is what happens when you speak to a girl. My
daughter, be aware. I say: Beware of dogs, my daughters.
Beware of dogs, my daughters. Beware of dogs, my daughters. Beware of the boy, for he is a liar, Ali. Beware of this boy, for he is a liar, Ali. Beware of this
boy, for he is a liar. Beware of you. May
God reward you. Beware of laziness, Zainab. Beware of laziness, Zainab. Beware of laziness, Zainab. Beware of laziness, Zainab. Beware of
laziness.  And
laziness, Zainab, beware of it! And smoking, beware of
it! It is the cause of deadly diseases.
Beware of it!
It is the cause of deadly diseases.
These magazines, my sisters, beware of them! These magazines, my
sisters!
Yes,
magazines! The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: Beware of envy, for envy consumes
good deeds as fire consumes
firewood.
The Prophet, peace
and blessings be upon him, said: Beware of envy, for envy consumes envy upon envy, and
fire consumes what it consumes.
Be careful, uncle, for people see you.
Hadith
not following
up. And he, peace and blessings be upon him, said: Beware of
sitting in the
streets. And he, peace and blessings be upon him, said: Beware of sitting. Peace and blessings be upon him, beware of sitting. And he, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: Beware of newly invented matters, for they are misguidance. And he, peace and blessings be upon him, said:
Beware of
matters, for they are misguidance.
I made the blackboard for you. She was
defamed in the press because of her controversial decision.
[Laughter] She was
defamed in the press because of her
controversial decision. So this sentence is more
like a bulletin sort of Arabic news report
type.  You get me?  What does that mean?
It means she was vilified.  She was
defedation.
Here is her decision, a decision, oh
decision, oh controversial decision,
controversial.
I don't think there's anything else to
mention now that is
in this portion. God willing, next week, the
fifth, God willing, and we will stop here. May God’s peace and blessings be
upon our Prophet Muhammad and upon his family and companions.
Peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon you.